each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
last 14 months which has been supported
by microsoft research connections and
yeah it's called predicting where on
earth life is and will be so just stop
talking about predicting like what what
that really means and like it's pretty
well demonstrated in this little video
clip which is our distinguished chief
scientist that marks off research
cambridge chris bishop i'll just turn
the sound off yeah and he's got this
steel ball they say i don't want the
sound of that so good he's got the steel
ball on a big wire and he's going to let
it swing out away from him i let it
swing back towards his face and like
everyone in everyone's crappy and
everyone thinks this is amazing but he
knew that that wasn't going to hit his
face physics is pretty predictable so
it's pretty boring but down here this
little guy here is his son like he
wasn't willing to let himself be minded
but they soon so like physics is pretty
predictable but that prediction lets you
sort of Dodge danger if you've got a
steel ball coming towards your face but
it also lets people do like massive
experimentation like like it soon which
costs 4.4 billion dollars or pounds or
but it's one of the biggest scientific
enterprise is only one scene but what
I'm going to talk to you today is about
the world biggest ever experiment which
is to do with climate change and how
humans are manipulating the whole system
so ecologists are interested in these
sort of natural resources which help
support like but we're interested in how
things like population growth affect
pressure on these systems also like all
the emissions in terms of pollution and
carbon dioxide emissions how that
affects the life-support system how
agriculture taking out massive amounts
of a tropical rainforest and natural
ecosystems how that affects the world
and then how that all ties in with
economic systems as well so like this is
a system what what affects the SI system
is also affected by the Earth's I system
so like this is quite complicated stuff
on the face of it so we're really like
we're talking about the world's worst
experiment here and it so it is of
serious concern like if we manipulate
the Earth system in such a way that we
damage it like like that actually
affects our day-to-day life right people
did think the LHC might create a black
hole and the whole earth would be just
destroyed but physics is probably
predictable enough that you knew that
wasn't actually going to happen but it's
well the worst experiment climate change
because we got no replication and we've
got no control so it's quite hard to
actually derive what is a climate change
effect versus some of the background
effects which are happening and also
we're losing all our experimental
material as we go along but we don't
actually make measures which affect our
study experiment in the right way things
will go extinct so we're going to be
able to run this experiment again and
also there's no off switch for climate
change like we're affecting your system
and it's going on on and I think the
final sort of their analogy to drop and
comparison is that for the LHC got the
tremendous amounts of collaboration
between scientists to actually get it
going but maybe in the study of climate
change in ecology we don't actually have
this sort of teamwork
going on at the moment so that was just
an introduction into the area so would
you really trust the ecological
predictions I would never put my face in
front of a steel ball which was
determined by on knowledge of the
Equality persistence so so in terms of
predicting where things are and where
they will be like this is a big
economics and social importance that
where will carbon be in the future where
will forests be in 100 years time and
how much of those forests will be there
where can I plant my crops and where can
we preserve biodiversity these are all
the sort of issues that we want to get
up and they're things which are of
importance the International
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change see these is like key sources of
uncertainty in what is going to happen
and featuring they really want new
methods and tools to address these
problems and these this is up our
research area on this project so from
all that like it's a big experiment it's
of great importance and there this is
the methodology that I research and from
that big importance it's usually brought
down to a current model with
correlations so it's a model of species
distribution usually combine information
on where that species occurs with layers
of environmental variables pull out some
sort of correlative relationship and use
that to predict forward but that isn't
really as complicated as maybe the
system underlying it is so that affects
our way how we can actually predict so
this is like people to really criticize
this area so it believes in a remarkable
structure rapidly simple structure to
ecological systems like they don't just
work by correlation
and simple associations and it means
that the predictions aren't actually the
political associations between climate
and species are actually only better
than chance and also their predictive
ability in terms of weather if the
climate warms weather species will go
north or south the results from these
sort of methods are no better than
tossing a coin so but this is pretty bad
news for ecology and everyone but then
taking it down even further people use
this sort of software quite a lot to do
this kind of regression analysis and
this is divided lots of criticisms of
criticisms of its own because you can
put data written and you can get stuff
out of it really really easy without
even having to know what the algorithms
are underneath and for a scientist
that's kind of oh yeah most people would
say something worse than criticism but
this is just one of lots of different
methods that people use out there but
this is drawn in lots of non scientific
issues with species distribution
modeling so people say it's more
computational convenience than actual
hard science or and it's also fragmented
the field so different software are
often built around their different
research communities are actually vice
verse that research communities around
software so then in review papers they
can have no common sight air citations
and then also people are really worried
about the policies that are being built
because of indiscriminate use of
software for science so back in the
words of Mark Abbott last night is
you've got these knowledge ecosystems
which is beep built around like the
scientific questions of policy demands
the software use so like it's quite a
complicated issue to get into so yeah
some people do live in these sort of
Italian villages where they do come and
go sometimes but also there's some areas
in this site
where people are in these fortresses and
they might not even know that they're in
the fortresses which is the worst thing
so we're not communicating beyond their
domain so just take Mark's analogies
even further from last night the kind of
science that we're attempting to do at
the moment it is it's more towards the
jungle situation but I think it's more
like in the botanical garden where you
get lots of species which would never
live together normally put them side by
side and then try and learn about all
those species at the same time and like
so we call this sort of scientific
approach joined-up ecology right we're
trying to think about the theory and
statistics at exactly the same time as
we think about how we're going to
visualize those results and design the
user interface for these software and
we've been trying to understand the
sociology of the scientists at the same
time is like being able to talk to them
on the deep level about the philosophy
of that subject so like it is immensely
ambitious to try and do all these
components at the same time but we
believe it's kind of the way we have to
do it to actually affect that scientific
discipline so
I'll just briefly talk a bit about the
science if that's okay so the big
problem with correlating T things
together is that you just assume that
what you're saying is the truth but in
ecology actually that's a bit of it so
we might have a species and it might
respond to temperature in a certain way
so there's certain temperatures that it
likes and there's certain temperatures
it doesn't like so much so we want to
get at that sort of response curve so
that we can predict how it would vary
with temperature say in terms of climate
change but what we might see in the real
world isn't it might not fulfilled its
potential response to that climate
because it might just not have had time
to in the areas that is reach and also
it might not have been able to reach all
those places because it can't disperse
far enough so then there that'd be like
a dispersal limitation or it might not
be in all the places that it could be
because a another species is out
competing it so what you observe is
different from what it actually could do
because of competition and then
similarly get some more boring ones
which you like statistical artifacts so
you might not have sampled everywhere in
the world so you might not have
information on everywhere where a
species disappear just because you
haven't gone there and also you might
not have measured the temperatures right
in the first place so then you've got
some statistical artifacts built into
your data and we see these things is
like they're five big problems for this
research area at the moment but luckily
three of them have kind of got proof of
principles of how you'd solve those
problems so we'd have to worry about
those so much
and I'll briefly whisk through some work
that we've been doing on these other two
so firstly like a lot of the data that
we deal with is a really large
geographic scales and data might just be
recorded like one piece of data in terms
of temperature say it might be recorded
for a really really large grid cell so
it might be fired by five kilometers and
then in our data it says it has exactly
one temperature rather than like a fully
very very intemperate up and down hills
etc et-cetera so this is called
regression dilutions so when you try and
get out the environmental response that
you need to be able to predict what
there's going to happen with climate
change you could just get the wrong
answer because the way that all the
numbers are averaged out within the data
means that you actually get like a
squashed response so that that is really
really important because that means that
all the predictions used in policy could
potentially be over predictions so
whether that little policy into a false
sense of security or not will depend on
all the methods that people have used so
you can see that the importance of this
statistical method is actually quite
important a long way down line once you
use that information but to inform
policy so we did the statistical
validation of a new method that we did
where we can pretty much perfectly
retrieve that response by using some
Bayesian methods where we have latent
variables so I won't bore you with the
details but by using a bit of ecological
understanding we can actually retrieve a
closer representation of what we thinks
going on underneath so like not just
applying computational methods to
everything
and getting it a little bit wrong
instead we're taking a different
approach where we're just really
thinking about what we need to do with
that data to get the right information
out I'll skip over this so then so we've
done that one is in fact as well so then
we got back to interactions to do as
well so this has been a big problem for
a species distribution model in for
other probably 15 years now that people
talk about it in every single paper but
no one provides the solution so
foolishly we thought that we could solve
it and it took quite a while to work out
but what we're doing here is trying to
work out what each species is working
out what the to the environment is on
the speech
really
right sir
but muddling all the different species
different mobile
Tron
it's complicated what
i equal log
that so this is say we've got that red
model but with this we actually get the
line response she's perfect what we
infer the speak the absence of all other
species and this is for climate
please
babe do it for every time quite
complicated
you
what
the
over like
you
use
on
she's distribution
you
focal algorithm takes it in
if we customize back to the beginning it
up there was we'll have
hi Ben to be
software the best so software so sure
where
people use
you
yes we
vice prenup is a real
computation
by them and need to take that into
account what yeah they also like to
decompose and our cities and recompose
them later so that means like tearing
apart make sure it's all right for the
species that they are modeling but then
be able to recompose it back up into
something that they can run in batch
mode or on clusters except for etc so
but people want to take the computation
to the data but I think the most
important message that we got out of
this was let the scientist into the
computation like a lot of the scientists
feel that the structure of the
computational systems that they're using
actually just put some on the outside
and they can't actually affect what they
are doing in the way that they want to
and that's just purely because of the
software so where we need to take that
into consideration so then we did the
interviews and then we did a online
survey so we developed to survey based
on all that the stuff that we found out
and we got about 600 replies in the
month which given our short time
horizons this project was really good so
of those 600 people which distribution
model only twenty-five percent said that
the species distribution modeling
methods was suitable to the study system
ie they didn't really think that
correlation was the right thing to be
doing but and then only a quarter of
them said that it was suitable to their
data so yeah like three quarters of
people saying that isn't very suitable
to our system or their data but they do
that anyway
and then about a fit said that they
understood the methods that they were
implementing so like seventy eight
percent of people are not really sure
what the method is that they're doing
but they're doing it anyway and a lot of
people said that it need improvement so
like consider when most people are using
it they don't understand it and they
don't think its success system that's
surprising but then ninety-four percent
of them said that they could do
something else so that's really
surprising that they're using something
that they don't think suitable they had
a different choice so scientists might
not like or understand their methods but
they could use it anyway and this is
partly this computational convenience
issue so like if we say that our
scientific methods that I showed you
before we're better like maybe people
wouldn't use them because these other
things are more convenient for them so
we have to take all these things into
account so like here but most people use
only two of these software so
considering those like 20 odd software
available it's surprising that
seventy-six percent just use these two
that are is probably the most widely
thing that's used in ecology for all
kinds of our beef and fish distribution
modeling is no different than it's a sin
tax base into interaction that you have
with the software versus maxent which is
a click and go you just have drop-down
menus and you can produce amazing
interactive visualizations within like
10 minutes of downloading the software
basically so where these are kind of at
different ends of the scale of what
software is available so
you need to be able to code and you need
to be able to use a mouse that's kind of
the difference but then what users were
saying like makes you a little bit
worried about the situation within the
science because non-scientific factors
are affecting the directions in science
so these are very different software but
in our you can kind of create all kinds
of analyses and like if you really want
to you can write you see code and have
it linked into our our code etc etc
whereas in maxx an your kind of limited
to what buttons it's actually got so
unsurprisingly you get lots of
independent researchers we were more
technically experience using our and Max
ain't uses a usually younger but these
are the people who are doing species
distribution modeling work always almost
a time they were using the last creative
software and they're often guided by
what it says in peer-reviewed articles
which isn't necessarily the be all and
end all but it's what someone said and
it's got into a journal yeah these
people who use our it but say that they
have control of the tasks that they want
to do whereas maxent users say that less
frequently but maxent users say taking a
short time to become effective and
productive and it takes a few steps to
actually complete the task that they
want to do so like this is just a some
preliminary analysis but it does start
show that non-scientific factors are
creeping into the scientific process so
as well as creating software you should
be creating the teaching to go alongside
that so you're producing the scientists
who are appropriate to use software so
like it's another level to the problem
get through there and then on top of
that we did a co-authoring study so we
looked at who would published with who
in the scientific literature so trying
to get a bit of a fix on how software
developers interact with the scientific
community so these are just the
collaboration that the co-authoring link
between developers that there's allowing
they published the paper together and
then the size of the circle is how many
public papers they've published so with
the exception of this guy he's published
absolutely loathes and collaborated with
quite a lot of developers most software
sort of created in a scientific
isolation so this is one software that's
another software that's another software
and they don't really interact with each
other which is strange considering how
much they should actually have in common
the Wendland developers actually
interact with each other it's more
indirectly through like power users
people who use a software a lot try and
work out what it's actually for and
they've been even more linked by super
users who collaborate with a lot more
developers a lot more scientists and
these guys are really really important
for developing the science and the
software at the same time so just an
example with the maxent software it was
published in 2006 and the original
method was showing the species
distribution model in 2004 then lots of
people have published with it all the
way up until now so that we've had like
1368 citations about software by 2011
but in 2011 that's when an explanation
of maxim was actually published in terms
of the people who use it so the paper is
going to be massive because there's so
many uses of the software out there but
before then they didn't actually have an
explanation
which was written in their terms for the
users so it's just an interesting think
like software in science code developer
at the same time so okay so all that
sort of journey that we've gone through
through the interviews this survey and
looking at the co-authoring it's kind of
made me think that this kind of software
which is the right what is the more
obvious software to be use is a wrong
software to produce like a in trying to
introduce a new scientific method into
the community we have to think about the
sociology of that community in terms of
its own domain and then think about some
of the computational challenges in that
context so we're like like all these are
different things that we're doing at the
moment either projects papers or
workshops and they're all feeding into
like us understanding the reality of the
scientific problem in terms of the
community and also in terms of the
technology so right whilst it is
difficult it's like an immensely rich
way to go about things so like if you
took anything away from the talk today I
would say good policy relies on good
science so bad policy is going to be
based on things which aren't necessarily
as sophisticated as they should be in
terms of
distribution model an example and that
good science relies on good software so
from top to bottom we really need to
think about the way we do science well
the way we do computational science
which time to pick software so yeah it's
not all me like a dream who's my main
boss we've worked a lot on the solid
ecology brand pal we've worked on like
philosophy of the nation that's been am
actually rich exercising kind of pure
ecology and all these people in middle
richard canton steven lara lucas and
kenji have been working together on the
scientific software which is when the
challenging but rewarding exercise as
well and practice microsoft research
connections and microsoft research
cambridge effectively done
I just I it's a kind of a question or an
observation but I think some of the
problem with software development in
science is it starts off with a postdoc
say developing the software and which
has done very much in thousand with not
a real software development policy and I
personally really feel sign should move
towards a user-centered software design
approach from the beginning so actually
involving scientists in the area and are
quite an iterative cycle of software
development it's an observation but also
question
you
issues as they're developing stuff and
they're yeah it is the mandan and takes
a lot of resources and time so yeah your
observations right and at that point
they don't really want to switch or they
are very reluctant to switch and there
has to be a good reason to switch once
they do that and they are I think
generally they are comfortable get or
getting comfortable in using two kids
and taking modules and assembling them
slightly different ways but where there
are very few people who are willing to
undertake the writing and generation of
a major software package so most of the
scientific community is sort of patching
with existing modules together a lot of
the today's scientific software is still
based on a very edge technology so some
of the roots are still in Fortran and
maybe transcribed from Fortran little
distributed computing mixed in and
generally very little source control so
so very very ancient 20 year old at
least 20 year old software methodologies
there are each PC users super computer
users they are a tiny fraction of the
community yet a lot of the resources in
the community both in software
development and in hardware resources
are spent on the supercomputing
community and there is very little
happening the rig that the results of
the simulations for example would ever
be accessible for a broader come
t data-centric computing is increasingly
important as Jim said so many times and
then much of the scientific software is
reinvented over and over again
unfortunately and no cheap of the chef
solutions are inside I mean cheap is of
course meant in quotation mark because
people generally don't pay for
scientific software or very very little
except for the occasional matlab license
or ID a license but the problem I would
like to focus on the of the shelf so so
really I will get a little bit into this
what's the economic so what's the price
of software well it's increasing and
it's a large fraction so specially for
some of the big science project so I
live through as the SS the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey and in the beginning the
plant software budget was two billion
dollars out of 25 the whole project
ended up to be a hundred and running the
software and the whole data processing
effort so writing and running the
software was a third of the project in
the end 30 million so this was the
biggest mistake we made I think when we
set up the project with Wei Wei
underestimated the software LSST is
doing better they are now estimating
that not to strictly the software
development but the costs related to the
software will be almost half of the
costs of the project overall one of the
challenges with these projects is we
cannot do everything for everybody okay
and so how do where do we draw the line
and there is the famous part although
the 8020 rule you know that eighty
percent of the West is in quantum is
owned by twenty percent of the people
but it also do you
isn't of the people who kept a ten
percent of the web pages and its source
so we cannot do a stream for everybody's
kind of take the 2010
you
so currently again in the wheel / and /
stonerow tell about the million lines of
code stars is completely in astronomy
clearly writing all the software ok and
Alice I believe by the way just finally
do right so they are trying to create a
lot better to be sustainable use from
community so
okay factors of 3 if i write code for
myself and i use it that's a unit one
cost if i want to give it to my music
Hector forever I want trap it and have
it used by a by the theater not a factor
of three who's paying for it so tight
right I'm not willing to the next fact
three there has to be
what is it and also we need to be able
to reap some for us please be right
front of me there may be a pure science
or vice versa okay the stop data but
what is it it's what we pay to get the
data but in a sense NSF pace
to create papers as index called a
reasonably success and okay so that
you
p added than it is worse
died off
you
are you
it and it will be reused times
we sort of the cost of total
for where and a bit modeling air pass so
again so if somebody hoop is this is
area so that the
you
budget rest of the scientific process
come back to move say and we are getting
to the point where we cannot even save
them
you
pressure and Hunter is existing Mac
sweet is so
two journals very pleased and be an mo
modular system because people are going
to take a few modules stick them
together in a different day create
another medulla and so on and this is
sort of the organic incremental
evolution of software archives are also
becoming computational services it's
basically cheaper to processed and move
and then we have to find the right
balance of trade offs in the what
between the features basically what is
the diversification and agility I will
get to it on my next slide what does
what does this really be in the world
everything is a fractal in the echo
system and everywhere we have to
understand that there are trade-offs in
everything that we do so that in if we
buy a computer we decide we don't want a
supercomputer but we want a desktop
machine or we want Amit sarcastic and we
have to understand also the science it's
very different trade-offs from the
e-commerce be the e-commerce you know
the gmail or hotmail or or the
transaction processing at the same time
there are lots of similarities to the
business analytics so ebay built for
example a remarkable environment they
have 600 statisticians working on the
data they buy they mining essentially
understanding the user Spector's that is
very similar I think the way we do
science impedance mismatch between a
monolithic large system and individual
users the gutsy realize this and that's
why they deal the tier 0 tier 1 tier 2
tier 3 hierarchy so they move ten
percent the ten percent most used parts
of the data down low level in the
hierarchy one step closer to do with us
and they again take ten percent of that
data and one step closer to the users
and this creates a very nice impedance
matching what is the pro in aggregating
two very large scales we can solve
problems that exceed the group size and
the current things and it forces people
to collaborate but where this was
discussed at Hopkins people freaked out
they said are we back to centralize
computing because they don't want any of
it because there is no trust with
related to a central organization and so
there is this so this is basically the
larger systems are more efficient or
smaller systems have more agility and I
can control my own environment in a
smaller system so i only have to trust
myself so how can you make it all play
nicely together and i think that the
answer is essentially that one has to
build a proctor like hierarchy so
computing and software and everything on
all scales instead what we built today
is basically having some very large
supercomputers and then essentially tiny
tiny clusters but without the whole
power law distribution in between what
we see then like in natural ecology and
ecosystems there is a natural
diversification happening so diversity
increases no matter what and we have
this natural evolutionary pressures I
find out a lot of dollars and and i
would like to milk every little bit out
of it so i'm tweaking the system if i
need lots of loading point calculations
i moved to GPU and then i take at least
and convert the kernel of my co two GPUs
because i get a factor of 100 out of it
if i have lots of i also i build a
system that runs hi um doubt which has a
high under number so which means i can
read very faster data and i don't break
up too much power and cpus we see stream
word processing emerging for some
projects and in software bees also see
here i just focus on the data in part of
the software a few years ago it was
basically a choice of trying to scrunch
software licenses from tony or see
server or to send lots of money to
oracle or to IBM or to use maybe my
secure entry linux today we have a bunch
of other options so there is a plethora
of no simple solutions emerging be lots
of free the column stores like money DB
then decided so Mike Stonebreaker is
building side a be so suddenly there is
this whole diversity of things to choose
from and it's all in flux which is great
because again I think real error in this
environment when there is a total chaos
there is also an opportunity so so even
a small group can actually come up with
some new ideas and create something
interesting so individual groups all on
subtle specializations but if you know
this this is all done on the surface
okay but there is what is remains in the
middle which is common is the data
management because nobody wants to do it
yet everybody has to do it and what we
see is that we see kind of boutique
systems are dead nobody can afford to
build a boutique software system anymore
it has to be put together from commodity
components same thing for hardware so
these are really generic patterns that I
see emerging sociology the big changes
are that more and more of the data
collection is happening in large
collaborations so you know it's the
Human Genome Project
the analysis is d-cup the coupled and of
the archive data which is great because
we had again decades of science growing
into ever bigger big science projects
and now we actually have again the
chance to do small science I can go to
the archive and if I have an idea I can
use this data in clever ways and we see
the emergence of the citizen and
Internet scientist the citizen science
where the internet technologies are
deeply embedded in every step of the
process in the power loss everything
comes in octaves and we have to realize
that the scientists may be just the tail
of our users so I think both Sloan and
galaxies would produce us that for
astronomy there was at roughly how many
about a hundred people are in the public
for every professional astronomer who
were using the data and embracing change
why would people change something that
they are comfortable with maybe current
tools are either inadequate for the job
or the new are thought better but it has
to be an overwhelming game to
essentially overcome the psychological
barriers so think about when do you
switch laptops it has to be a factor of
a few faster it has to be a factor
suffered to light there it has to be or
it has to be much easier to use or there
is a peer pressure that all my friends
switch to the new laptop okay and we
have to realize that many small steps
are much much easier than a single big
one so and and this is there is a
message here because in the outside
world the boundary conditions change
every year so 12 years ago it was korba
then it was grid grid computational grid
was everything and that was here to stay
then it was grid services then it was
web services today it is the cloud and I
bet that in five years there will be
something different
and we don't do what it is but there is
the Gartner hype curve always the
current heart technology is at the peak
so and our job in a sense the core
science is also that we have to dampen
the impact of all these changes in
computer and information technology on
the community because they are not going
to switch every two years we have to
break it down into lots of little steps
for the community and the last bit i
would like to reflect on standards and
services because again in this
environment where we set up these bigger
and bigger projects i have seen this
proliferation of standards so standards
are good no question to our standards
are even better because i have sinned
blue it's much easier for projects to
design hundreds of different standard is
building small serve small services
which use only a small number of these
but they are very cleverly design so
there is a lesson to be learned from
dropbox or s3 which where the interface
and the api is jokingly simple yet they
are doing exactly what is needed and
this is the challenge
I'm train earlier and she asked me to
talk a little bit about a project that
we're running the moment which we've
called the smart research work which is
actually taking some bits of software
which somebody pointed out we're
entirely developed initially in our labs
and then trying to make them usable for
other people and I'm not sure the factor
of three is correct I think it's more
like a factor of 10 when you look at the
effort required to redo the things you
should have done correctly from the
start so the issue is we're in a lab
everybody wishes that they recorded
their data a lot better at the beginning
there's a lot of personal agenda to get
it right you will save a lot of time
yourself let alone the agenda in the for
the supervisor who wants to use the data
after the student is left you know the
graph that you have to measure I don't
have enough details it doesn't work now
sometimes that's for real mostly it's
because you failed to record your what
you actually did so we're all smart
people but sometimes has smart people we
need a lot of help we're too busy
concentrating on one thing want to get
the software you say really simple
record these experiments get the stuff
down get it recorded as accurately as
you can with as much context as its
extractable from the student in
reasonable amount of time as they learn
it works better then they'll put more in
we also have some other agendas there is
unfortunately fraud in science support
in every community there's also getting
caught up with things that you're not
really done anything wrong but your
media profile is not appropriate and
those guys got caught again recently
they are really very unfortunate in you
a and the lesson is as the BBC show
you're working probably taught that at
school why does it change it doesn't the
whole business is sure what you've done
and be able to show what you've done so
you've got to record it properly the
long tail has been referred to in foster
was looking at so the NSF numbers are
there grants have a long tail effect
this is the size of the institutions in
the UK and the higher education
institutions and you can see there's a
long tail here few Oxford Cambridge in
period up here the rest of us all down
here and we've all got to work together
and it's very costly to get the software
to work together but it's also very
working let's look at the students
because if you don't provide the
software the students will have to write
it that time takes them away from doing
their chemistry or physics and of course
they'll write it themselves because they
won't have the ability to look around
and pinch it so the real essence is
lesson is not invented here is good not
bad that is a real problem some
programming so they know what's going on
but most of them should avoid doing it
most of the time and leave that to other
people to write the programs but leave
it such a way that it can be adjusted
and configured when necessary lowering
the barrier to adoption I think that's
probably going to be the biggest lesson
why the cloud is useful because you can
put up the services they don't need to
make arrangements with anybody else to
use the service potentially just get a
credit card out and that's about the
worst and if it's a Dropbox system as
being pointed out you can get going
anyway course intuitive usable software
we need open standards so not only very
few standards they've got to be very
open and the data has got to be stored
in a way that doesn't lock it in to a
commercial system and worry you about
where you're going to get out when it
all changes and we want to facilitate
the term the collaboration and this must
provide a much greater degree of
provenance as you're recording it so
that when you finally produce the paper
it is all available our projects funded
under an ish ative in the UK called the
university modernization fund most of
that money is being spent on making sure
the student records can be moved around
the university's something that it
doesn't work very well and we've got a
little bit of it and we're trying to
replace the written lab notebook and
we've seen how expensive paper is we try
and do a bit better you can look at some
of the details on the websites but
basically we've got a system a couple of
three systems one of which is a fairly
simple blogging system but designed
around the data so that scientists can
record what they're doing with
relatively minimal metadata ie we don't
force people to do things we've got
another system coming in which is much
more semantic that if your community is
ready for it then it takes advantage of
it and we also route a lot of the data
around in the lab with the message
passing system because on the grounds
that you can get the data off the
equipment and into your lab notebook
without this to anybody intervening it's
much more likely people will comment on
it they're there by starting the
chain and improving system and the idea
was to deploy this software in the cloud
and one of the reasons for doing that is
actually to attract people to using this
cloud that the HD sector is going to
fund what was going to fund might fund
not quite clear so again it's very
important software's usable otherwise it
will defeat the purpose of the funding
some of our software is being used
around the world to this blogging sounds
part of the open notebook science so
it's actually it's nice because we can
actually make those lab notebooks
available and people can see what we're
up to the more semantic version actually
allows you to generate new types of
these lab notebooks by taking our blog 3
engine adding in an ontology such as a
planning and a current one that makes
into a lab notebook you can slot in
other intelligence here as and when
they're available and get more powerful
ektron o'clock notebook but again only
worth doing if the community is ready to
do that otherwise it just causes more
trouble and will stop people using it in
chemistry we are sadly lacking in freely
available and easily usable services got
lots of money you can get some but we
make much use of the ones that are
around for example chemspider and so we
have a variety of ways of putting
molecules in and it pumps it round in a
cycle to produce all of the information
or find all the information that might
might or might not be known about the
molecules you're putting in including
course or the safety information and in
the UK you are required to fill in your
safety forms before you start an
experiment and we have systems that make
use of that plan in advance to provide
the metadata in advance of doing
experiment much easier to get people to
do it in advance then afterwards when
they're they finish with the experiment
so I said we pumped the data around use
a message-passing system we currently
use an IBM system but we move the
messages around and they can be archived
displayed on all sorts of different
devices that the broker system makes it
much easier to add a new services to
that and one of the main ones of course
is to get it into your lab notebooks
from which you can comment we can also
then look at the data in lots of
different ways on your smartphone or out
on the web and one of the important
things that I feel it's necessary to
make it feasible to do is you plot up
your data like this you would have in
parallel the environmental data at the
lab so you know what the conditions were
click on the point here and you get the
data that's behind it and so on tracking
back all the way through to your order
data find the big spikes when somebody
wandered into the room and cause some
trouble
you
tis from
provide that
it's been writing poor soft they weren't
bothered that's big
noam resources very much
we didn't have questions we
you
questions
it being too up to the audience here is
one video prior so
sky AV AG off with a question of the
previous speaker
on one of these top comments we all done
you
so as new
but my is and is not come up
Prince it's clear that one needs to
happen is it to the and a check process
of
we reward doing things we think are so
the way that you presented making sure
that we change the interact making sure
that we use that we we change the
process software for site so you change
huge reward
there cannot be a stick
you
so
part it Jordan I can be kind of two
built first of all I will see whether i
can buy it because it's already been
made by somebody so commercially
preferably for some other use it will be
cheap enough but I'm allowed to oh honey
just if
but if I our technicians you go to talk
extraordinary skill yes who will then do
and they have a Krypton that
moves that work the problem is that
we're running too near the curve of what
can be done and so that we've got a man
though the people that you're asking to
be the equivalent of the technicians are
difficult to rule also think that we put
our technicians nearly enough for the
things that they already do our glass
blowers extraordinary skilled so we have
to recognize that that technical backup
is part of the work and of course
putting them on the paper is the first
move and that's often not being done
with the workshops it is done a little
bit more with the software but not done
enough and not enough recognition that's
what it comes back down to in the end I
think that's the problem if we just if I
as a chemist go and try and get hold of
a software developer I have a major
trouble finding the rights of people
well if there's my graduate and post doc
increasing yes I try and send them and
park them with people the only people
for example which you set up so that
they do learn the right skills now it is
questionable whether all of them I have
some students physical chemists often go
off in this area I'd rather send them
out in to the software industry having
understood what software engineering is
about more interdisciplinary
interactions would help this because
then they would be being supervised by
people who actually do understand that
and that would help so I think a wider
more dispersed training would be good
and also like to make an analogy I think
software in many sense it's a little bit
like the art so that there are people
where so 10 mediocre people don't make
up a really brilliant program or a
really good programmer and 10 brilliant
programmer or 10 very good programmers
to don't make up a brilliant programmer
is this same thing this with art so so
we should reward it also somehow
okay so it's not easier to train a
computer scientist to write the
chemistry software than a chemist to
write the computer science software
we're trying a test case i have an
extraordinarily talented computer
science students working for me and i
would say in a team he can help write
the chemistry software because he can
write with with with effort and i would
hope that i am in an unusual position to
bridge this gap we can work out what
needs to be done but no actually each of
these disciplines at its core if i take
one of my extraordinary talented organic
chemistry colleagues there is no way
that the talented computer scientist is
likely to be able to have the insight
necessary and therefore without
interacting with them and seeing what
they're doing they won't with the
relevant bridges they won't actually
write the right software when we've seen
that many times you have very
interesting software but it's not any
use to the chemist so I think you have
to get the groups of people together and
you have to find a language which they
can talk together in which we can talk
together and we did do that with with
but I'm kind of trying to say that you
need the computer scientists involved a
bit more are you need to do because it's
they're very much on the fringes oh I
would agree that we have been very lucky
to work with computer science
departments that have a significant
interest that in doing these science yes
you need you need it is it's like the
pure and applied chemistry have the same
problem you need both the theoretical
founding and they'd software developers
you need all of them working together
yeah and I would like to add though that
bringing sort of a chemist and the
computer scientist together is also a
necessity because today's people are
very much i shaped so they are very deep
in their own narrow areas but ideally it
would be good to have people who are
equally deep in both areas that who both
can actually write a software and
understand the computer science
principles and algorithms and data
structures and also know the chemistry
and I think it's not unreasonable to
expect or artists to seek to train such
people it over the next 10 years
I like to be provocative in return said
computer scientists aren't necessarily
the best writing software they may do
research in computer vision there may do
research in machine learning but they're
not typically writing software programs
which are complicated things and I came
to the conclusion and it was partly with
the omi I that you need three types of
people you need computer scientists for
novel algorithms you need scientists who
know what the problems are and you need
IT experts who can write software but i
think i think i would also now think
that there was the fourth character
quarry which is you need the people who
are experts at understanding and seeing
what people actually do because it's the
user interface problem and actually you
can get your even tality programmers who
can program anything you can get the
cameras who are doing things and they
can sit there together and they can
completely miss what was actually needed
to make it work and there are a few
individuals who can sit there and and
they just look at the screen on they
look at the people and they'll tell you
you need to move that box from here to
there a totally trivial change right
except it makes all the difference to
making it work and and that's another
skill that's in there somewhere that
we've haven't valued enough it is
designed it is it yeah it's why you open
some boxes the right way around but
there's also a huge cultural effects on
that the example I give my wife's first
language goes to the opposite direction
to mine so when there are banker
switches by the wall and there and I say
it's the first one you can imagine the
arguments we get into because she's
always switches they were opposite one
to me so there are deep cultural issues
about where things should be so design
depends on culture and the culture and
the design and need to be reflected in
the software that's underneath can I
take a follow-up to that I think yep I
agree with that basically it's not a
case of saying that there are there are
certain specials that required for for
creating good scientific software its
case that there are always specialists
in it's a case of understanding which
specialists are required for your
particular domain and there's not one
size fits all some some will require
user interfaces and some will require
domain knowledge some require software
engineering knowledge some require
algorithms what I think is still missing
though is for us
a scientific community to get to the
point where we have these teams standing
as a match of course we because what I
do what I've seen in some other
communities is very interesting I'll
give an example from the geosciences the
geosciences we were looking this as a
comparison to the idea of could you have
a standing force of software engineers
that could be loaned out to the
community so you know you you have a
pool of resource that that can be called
on by any research group and the analogy
was made with the geosciences where that
they have a similar thing for doing ship
inspections so you get the ships which
go out onto the ocean collect data come
back again so you have ship inspectors
that check the seaworthiness of these
ships and what's happened is that
because there's been a long-term
contract for one or two companies to
look at these ships you've ended up with
ship inspectors who happen to know a lot
about the way that science is performed
on ships and you have people who are
ocean-going scientists who happen to
know a lot about the best way to make
their ships pass inspection so you've
had a coming together and because you've
had a standing set of people within that
community you gain more than simply
having generic ship inspectors coming in
and I think that's where we we need to
be for science is that we're not yet at
the point where we consider for instance
software developers numerical algorithms
experts as being standing members of our
communities it happens because they are
exceedingly brilliant people who want to
collaborate not as a matter of course
and I think that's really where we need
to get to
you
I just have a comment I don't know it's
another question certainly but it's one
of the observations I've made so I'm
currently in a project in Australia
where we provide an e research
infrastructure for urban researchers at
the same time I sure household my
partner she's an immunologist and what
I've observed often is that we might be
perceived by a lot of scientists from
different domains as being a little bit
arrogant because we tell them how they
should be doing their stuff and also
because we're deeply passionate about
improving the tools and thinking that it
can be done better but they don't really
care how the a nice can be done better
or let this you know you could script it
better or whatever you just want to do
their stuff not our stuff better and so
that that's just one of the observations
I don't know how to come through core of
the problem but I think communication
and and really try to work for them not
for us in it so you know another gym
great code feels appropriate here so Jim
said that I love those collaborators who
are desperate and they are willing to
change their ways but i think the other
side is what's the reward because if
your if your commission to do something
and that's the the way and you get your
reward through a financial arrangement
you will do within reason what is
requested you will advise them some
things but that but if actually you're
trying to get the reward because by
doing the best and new way of doing it
you will get the paper as well then of
course there's different driving forces
and those will pull apart it's certainly
true there I do know some people are
very arrogant quite rightly they can do
the better job and it is always knowing
in any piece of research when it's the
best time to stop and actually get some
results out rather than keep getting
things better it's very difficult and it
depends upon the relationship between
you and it's these long-term
relationships which will produce the
best yield but the driving forces for
promotion for ten year whatever tend to
work against many of these things at the
moment
stimulation some discussion which I'm
hopeful go on into the evening so I just
like to thank everybody in